so you've obviously created your own
brand for yourself online tell me a
little bit about what people can get
when they go to ijustine.com you know i
do a lot of sketch comedy videos a lot
of entertainment but i also blog about
different startups social networking and
you know crazy fun things that are going
on
what you've done in the past is life
casting so you're wearing a camera on
your head what was that like yeah i did
wear a camera on my head now when i look
back at that i was like are you serious
did i really do that it was kind of this
really weird social experiment where it
was like these people were literally
interacting with my life i would walk
past the starbucks they'd paypal me five
dollars hey i just thought i just seen a
starbucks but even that it was just this
weird connection with people they had
like this look into my life and
just very very strange it was a lot of
fun
i love doing laundry what was the
strangest thing that happened while you
were live casting probably people
showing up places
they would see oh justine's two blocks
over so they would just go and show up
and most of the time it was completely
harmless which was a good thing i mean i
try to keep like my family and like
personal life you know somewhat private
because if you give everybody everything
like that's very invasive and you kind
of just takes away from you know you
being able to live your life normally
i'm taking the internet with me so i
really would love to take tech
mainstream like we have such a small
audience there's so many people out
there that i think would love to know
about all the things that we're doing
all the great new technology so that's
kind of i'd love to find a way to do
that i told
you will kiss my hips now shut up and
let me go